what is the perfect day look like for
you if we're talking about writing an
hour-by-hour schedule of a perfect day I
get up early I go to the gym I have
breakfast with some friends of mine I
welcome early by the way that's like a
Halloween a.m. a.m. so we're talking
really early really early you know I'm
crazy early it's ridiculously early yeah
but and I haven't done that always but
that's kind of what what what I'm on now
so I'm in bed like it when I'm with my
my nephew's that are like 4 years old
and 3 years old I'm in bed before them
ok you got a beat you wake up it's a
sorry you said exercise first yeah and
what does that look like what's exercise
for you I go to the gym I have a trainer
I have a couple guys that I work out
with and I'll you know it's maybe an
hour maybe a little more I'll do a
little warm-up before of stretching
afterwards take a shower go have
breakfast but it's an intense kind of a
thing that I definitely don't want to do
that's hard
you know so you feel like you've
accomplished something first thing yeah
it's a big accomplishment of the day at
the same time it's not like so hard that
I'm completely exhausted you know and
then I'll come home and handle whatever
correspondence and stuff has to be done
and then I work for maybe 3 hours and
then I just sort of crash the office is
closed I turn the switch I don't think
about any I don't think about anything I
don't think about the work at all do you
listen to
oh I mean afterwards after work once the
office is closed but during so this was
like 12 to 3 kind of thing something
like that sounds like that but the you
listen to music know if and yes that's
just me I mean I don't think you know if
somebody could be fast in different ways
it's fascinating you know the I mean
you've also of most of many writers
you've really but like I've heard
Stephen King's in writing is you've
optimized this come
conversation with the museum having that
optimized but you've at least thought
about it so what can you say a little
bit more about the trivialities of that
process of like you said facing the wall
what's do you have little ritual I mean
like the granular aspect of granular
aspects yeah
is there little rituals I do have all
kinds of well I'm not even going to tell
you I'm sure but the one thing and I
don't want to like to talk about this
too much because it sort of jinxes
things I think but the one thing I I do
try to do is when I then when I sit down
I immediately get into it first second
yeah I don't sit and [ __ ] around with
anything immediately try to get into it
as as quickly as I can and the other
thing is that writing a book or
screenplay or anything like that is a
process of multiple drafts and it's the
first draft that's where you're most
with the muse where you're going through
the blank page like right now I'm on I
don't know what the fifth or sixth
seventh draft of some other thing I'm
working on so when I'm I've got pages
already written and I'm kind of reading
them afresh as I as I go through the
story so it's not quite where I am now
it's not quite a deep Muse scenario
partly it is but it's also sort of
bouncing back and forth between the
different between the right brain and
the left brain I'm kind of looking at it
and trying to evaluate it then I'm going
into it and try to change it a little
bit when uh do you know sit down get
right into a dino the night before of
what that starting point is yeah I
always try to stop and I learned this I
think Hemingway wrote about this or done
Steinbeck or one of the or maybe both of
them to always stop when you kind of
know what's coming next so you're not
I'd have facing a chasm you know yeah
okay so and afterwards when you're done
the office is closed offices closed I
let the muse take care of it you know I
don't know I don't want to
think it's a very unhealthy thing to
worry about it or think about any
creative process you don't I got a long
walk later think about yeah if that then
I will sort of keep my mind open to it
but I won't be like obsessing about it
yeah that's actually on walks sometimes
things are popping your head you know
and you go oh oh I should change that
but that's not your ego doing it that's
a deeper level okay so how does the day
end to go in terms of writing
so yeah the writing you know writing the
office door closes and then the rest of
the day just do whatever that maybe go
out to dinner my girlfriend is not here
now she's in New York working we'll make
dinner or whatever go out to dinner
something like that and maybe maybe I'll
read something nothing heavy and I go to
bed pretty early and the gym is a big
thing for me already if sorry probably
would you like with you with martial
arts the night before I'll be I'll be
visualizing what I have to do the next
day and getting myself psyched up for
that and then let's conk out like a
light and wake up at the crack of dawn
you